the only thing that can be short of
about the future is it will be
absolutely candid I'm Patrick Coleman
and today we're bringing you an
interview between our associate director
Bryan Keating the astrophysicist and
author of the recent book losing the
Nobel Prize with one of the preeminent
scientific minds of the 20th and 21st
century
Freeman Dyson you have such a remarkable
career you've been an inspiration for
many of us younger physicists throughout
the generations you have that rare
quality which is not only do you have
great longevity of your ideas and
influence but you've had the good
fortune to to go through so many
different generations of physicists and
see so many different levels of physics
throughout your career and you've not
only had great impact on my career in
other people's careers but you've
influenced popular culture in a way that
few physicists have in fact I'm gonna
give a quote that Oliver Sacks the late
great Oliver Sacks said of you he said a
favorite word of Freeman's about doing
science and being creative is the word
subversive Freeman you feel that it's
rather important that not only you be
create the you be Orthodox but you also
be subversive and you Freeman have done
that all your life I wonder and it's me
speaking now if you've thought about the
different ingredients behind your
intellectual capacity in particular for
the creativity and imagination that we
so deeply are interested here in the
arthur c-- clark center no but it's more
true of all of us actually it is of me
and he's a lot he's been a lot more
subversive than I have but no of course
I like to be subversive but the most
important work I did in fact was just
the opposite
it was ended up very conservative I was
hoping so to upset the whole Apple
trials of physics and what actually came
out was that the earth
were good I had to accept that that's
the way nature thinks and that's the way
we have to think too so so the actual
work I was doing wasn't subversives at
all although my intentions were you
failed at being subversive how radical
of you and that quite often happened so
do you hope to create a revolution and
to end up just deciding after all the
experts were righted so for the benefit
of our listeners who may not be familiar
with the revolution you're talking about
could you expand upon it briefly yeah
well this was in the nineteen forties
that we had a theory of quantum
electrodynamics which was a theory of
atomic radiation
this was a basic series that was a
required for understanding physics or
understanding about atoms to how they
interact with light but the theory was
mathematically a mess it it was
producing stupid answers which are
obviously wrong so everybody was
thinking that oh we have to have
something radically new some wonderful
new ideas and it turned out my book was
actually just to fix up the mathematics
to get rid of a lot of the mathematical
nonsense and what was left over turned
out to be correct so in the end we
rehabilitated the old theory rather than
creating a new one very interesting so
one thing I'm always curious about and I
tend to ask is one of my favorite saw
horses on these podcasts is whether or
not creativity is like mathematics or
even great art in that it could be or
can it be in european-- and can it be
taught or is it something you can merely
nurture and if you're not born with a
certain amount of creativity imagination
as a physicist or as an intellect can
you can you actually learn or teach
somebody to be
so the answer is yes I mean surprisingly
so that actually even Mozart had a
teacher named Lehighton I mean if you
look at great musicians and great
artists and great scientists they all
had mentors and stars I know and in case
it's an unconscious process across it
means you don't sit down and teach how
to make great music but you just make
some music yourself try it out it's a
mostly a matter of practice but practice
guided by other people's knowledge and
experience but I always say Mel for
myself that III do both calculating
science and also writing English and
both cases I always it's the fingers
that do the thinking that I can I can't
really think about a problem in the
abstract just walking in the country and
thinking that doesn't work I have to sit
down as a desk and actually calculate
something or actually write something
and as the fingers move somehow the
thoughts come and I think that's true of
many of us that because if some
musicians particularly the fingers
really are doing the thinking in the
case of music and I don't I think
science in many ways is very much the
same yeah absolutely
okay so bringing or connecting those two
digital practices of using your fingers
both mathematics and in literature
writing how do you how do you find you
know switching between the two is it a
natural phenomena for you that you that
you're it's relatively simple for you to
switch between between writing English
as you say and
writing mathematics no it was very much
a conscious decision I was very happy
doing science when I was young and
science is really a young man's game and
then there comes the midlife crisis when
you're 40 years old and you suddenly
realize you're not so smart as all these
young people around you and you better
find another line of work and soon in my
case the other line of work was writing
and it turned out to be a very
productive enterprise I wrote a number
of books they sold well and I found in
many ways it's opened writing books open
doors and widened my circle of friends
very much so it became I became much
more of a public figure Roth as a writer
than I was as a scientist so I've
enjoyed the second half of my life it
was a conscious decision that science is
really a young man's game as writers can
continue to write it into the 90s and
they don't seem to deteriorate so much
so in that case it certainly has worked
out very well and the next question I
want to ask is the is the broad panorama
that is that is characteristic of your
work from spanning the very most deepest
underpinnings of the atom and the
nucleus and all ranging all the way out
into the deep interstellar voids and I
wonder you know when you think about the
distant future you know I've heard you
speak about the the four revolutions
that you've witnessed in your lifetime
beginning with the space revolution and
kind of the the the generation that
we're in now with the exploration of
space but even that's started with you
during the there
and you're you're you experienced the
early part of the space race and even
living in England during the war and
having to undergo some of the shelling
by by Hitler's forces using Wernher von
Braun's technology I wonder you
mentioned once that in some ways you
were influenced by arthur c clarke who
is of course the namesake of this of
this organization that were part of and
i wonder you know has it has this you
know capacity for expanding the very
small to the very large is that is that
in any way that cut just come naturally
to you that you were able to think the
small picture to the big picture was
that something that came easily to you
yes i mean i have a short attention span
but i like to jump around from one thing
to another that so that's just my
temperament and it's means i don't
generally think deep thoughts i'm you
just usually just listening to the
latest gossip and that's what i mostly
do I mean really are two kinds of
scientists the deep thinkers and there
are problem solvers the deep thinkers of
course are the most important they're
the people we really Revere the most
people like Einstein and Heisenberg and
interact those people who solve big
problems by sitting down and really
staying with one problem for 10 years
until they have it that's not my style I
just I I actually work very hard on a
problem for a few weeks and then either
I solve this or I don't in either case I
finished so I go ahead and do something
else which means that I don't take so
deep but I do I spread more broadly we
need both kinds but I certainly have
disrespect both for the good problem
solvers like my teacher Hans bethe
was a the champion problems over but
also not a deep thinker and and there
are others of course like Ed Witten my
colleague and friend in Princeton who
has done nothing but deep thinking all
his life so one thing that you've been
particularly in the news for in the last
few years especially so with the
discovery of a remarkable star that
seemed to have a lot of unusual activity
that's colloquially known as tabbies
star this this star that had activity
that couldn't be explained at least
initially by ordinary Astrophysical
phenomena and it was conjectured there
might be an advanced signals of an
advanced technology or civilization that
might be somehow orbiting this star and
it sort of evoked a renewed or rekindled
an interest in what are known as Dyson
spheres and I wondered if you could
first describe the inspiration for that
it has been said that you a credited
science-fiction author Olaf Stapledon
perhaps planting a seed that would
germinated the idea of the Dyson Sphere
at first I wonder if could you describe
the the genesis of that idea and then if
we have time I'd like to explore the
topic of other civilizations and maybe
sending life from earth out to other
civilizations but first on Dyson spheres
was that influenced in any way by by the
writing of yes well this is a little bit
complicated because the whole notion of
Dyson spheres a misunderstanding and so
a bit I have to explain what I actually
was was trying to do and what actually
happened which was quite different so
there was a couple of friends of mine
Philip Morrison and Giuseppi cocconi who
were physicists at Cornell they had the
idea of listening for alien
civilizations by radio it was a time
when radio telescopes were just getting
good so they proposed to listen for
alien signals in the sky by radio and
that sounded like a very good sister
good idea so I was quite excited about
that but I asked them the question well
what do you do with this aliens don't
want to communicate and how do you
detect non communicate
non communicating aliens and the answer
which I came to was you look for waste
heat that any advanced civilization if
it has a big industry or big population
would have to get rid of a lot of waste
heat and the only way you can get rid of
waste heat in the large scale is
radiating it into space so it becomes
infrared radiation so what you should
look for is infrared sources in the sky
objects in the sky which are infrared
radiating a lot of waste heat away in
the form of infrared so I suggested that
and published this in magazine science
that was about fifty years ago and so
waited to see what would happen but
unfortunately I used the word eius eius
fear to describe the habitat of these
aliens you were looking for it would be
living in some kind of an environment
and this environment this habitat would
have an outside surface what you would
actually see was the warm outside
surface of whatever the aliens had built
and but I used the word biosphere and
the science fiction writers
misunderstood that me in a big round
ball which of course it wasn't at all
what I had in mind and the real habitat
would be much more like just a
collection of
orbiting objects in space which would
have a big surface but they would have
to be so disconnected objects orbiting
around so that they tend to require to
be physically very strong they they
could just be so big balloons with
aliens living inside anyhow so the
science fiction writers got a wrong idea
of that but the right idea of the actual
picture of aliens orbiting around stars
in big balloons actually does come from
a science fiction writer Olaf Stapleton
and he was describing the the advanced
civilizations in a book called Star
Maker which is a book one of my
favorites science fiction books I mean
it belongs to this John which I call Co
fiction it's not really science and
fiction but just a combination of
theology and fiction which staples are
most particularly good at so that
picture of the galaxy with its alien
civilizations absorbing the light and
turning it in for infrared that's
clearly described in in that book of
stapleton so it is in fact where I got
it from sticking on the topic of
potential extraterrestrial intelligence
and why we might not have seen the
evidence for such existence of such
extraterrestrial intelligence there's
the famous so-called Fermi paradox which
is if you calculate the abundance of
alien civilizations potentially with a
modicum of realism in terms of physical
properties that would be needed or even
just the probability of such
civilizations arising you come up with a
probability that's greater than zero and
Fermi's famous paradox was you know
where are they
and if there's if there's even a slight
probability given enough time there
should be some some degree of
probability that they would have visited
and made contact or produce signals that
are potentially visible to you earth
civilization so I wonder how do you
reconcile the the in your mind what are
some of them more plausible solutions to
the Fermi paradox I don't regard that
really as a paradox I think I mean it's
a mystery but it's not the same thing I
mean the universe is full of mysteries
that's that's just one of the biggest of
them but there are all sorts of
mysteries and one of the big mysteries
of course is the origin of life we don't
know how we originated and we have no
idea whether that was just a colossal
accident which was enormous to be
actually but it just it happened and we
are the result or we might be that it's
quite a common occurrence and that for
some reason life doesn't survive very
long that it has so many bad things can
happen that life may be quite common in
the universe but it usually goes extinct
so I mean all sorts of possible
explanations so I don't regard it as
strange that we haven't discovered
aliens I just it's a mystery why we
don't find aliens and I'm always
expecting to find them I think I mean
but I won't claim I can't calculate the
probability there's no way you can
calculate a probability on the basis of
one event and we only know one kind of
life that's us and so whether it's
probable or improbable we just don't
know and the question of whether or not
we should be looking for life that looks
like us we've talked about this
time but the you know is it you think
it's a necessary precursor that life
follow some sort of pattern that's
reminiscent of the way nature seems to
work on earth absolutely not I've been
to nature always has more imagination
than we have in don't that's so if you
if you want to guess what your gave to
discover it's not really a discovery so
the next topic I wanted to talk about
was potential ways to visit or send our
portions of our species out into the
interstellar medium within our galaxy
and you had actually a very storied
history with with space flight including
working on the so-called Orion project
and I was wondering with the recent
developments including as we record this
in March of 2018 there were only last
month did Elon Musk's and and SpaceX
send a Tesla Roadster into into the
solar system with an orbit that he
initially said at least would last for a
billion years or so and the question of
getting even beyond our solar system
using advanced propulsion systems I
wonder first could you describe what the
Orion program was about and its current
status as well and then we could get
into where you see this might be going
in the in the future
good well of course yuri milner the
russian supporter of wild years is doing
very well he has this breakthrough
project which he is just established
with real money and so he's actually
pushing ahead with what he calls on
Alpha Centauri mission that is an
interstellar mission and I think this is
wonderful this is quite new only started
a few months ago and we have no idea
really what's coming going to come out
of it but it obviously is the right sort
of a project if you want to go ahead
with ambitious
new technology what I was doing with
project Orion that was now for sixty
years ago it was very different I mean
that was by comparison a very modest
project to use nuclear bombs to drive a
spaceship and that was something we
really knew how to do nuclear bombs in a
way very simple things they are they're
just big packages of energy that you can
explode and you can use them for all
kinds of purposes particularly murdering
people so we wanted to use nuclear
weapons for doing something different it
wasn't murdering people and so the
project was actually started here in San
Diego with the general atomic company
which is still here and so we actually
had a project to build this
nuclear-powered spaceship which we
called Orion but that was not an
interstellar mission
it was very definitely solar system it
would it could reach velocities of the
order of 30 kilometres per second which
is speed the earth goes around the Sun
so it's a very good speed for a solar
system mission but it's not at all good
for interstellar so Orion in it from
that point of view was a rather simple
and conservative project they would have
had enormous consequences they would
have meant she really cheap and massive
missions inside the solar system
visiting planets and satellites and
comets so to the great shame it didn't
go forward on the other hand the reasons
for stopping it was in fact a good
reason that it was extraordinarily messy
when you explode bombs all over the
place you needed a large number of
for each mission the order of 2,000 per
mission so it meant a huge amount of
radioactivity being spewed around all
over the place including the planet
Earth so we calculated what we knew
about the effects of radioactivity on
human health and as far as we could tell
it sort of it worked out that every
mission we flew we would probably kill
roughly one person but with that with
considerable uncertainty might have been
as many as 10 might possibly have been a
hundred so anyway I thought it was quite
unacceptable and I think the public
considered it unacceptable then and even
much more so now so I would say it's a
dead project for good reasons it simply
was too filthy to be tolerated by a
civilized society so anyway with that so
it's I don't regret having worked on it
it was exciting at the time but I don't
regret having killed it I actually
justified in the Senate hearing to
ratify the test-ban treaty which they
don't impossible so I'm sort of proud of
that toward very good yeah we'll get
back to politics a little bit later
hopefully hmm but well actually so you
mentioned these projects which in some
sense were nucleated either by General
Atomics I've mentioned the connection to
the SpaceX which is a private company
and it seems like the in many ways a lot
of big projects are being undertaken not
by governments not by entities that have
you know vastly superior fortunes even
though there are you know very many
wealthy billionaires that are funding
prizes like break through listen and
and also Elon Musk's for-profit
companies what do you think of the new
money kind of influence that's occurring
in in science to guide projects and
directions and pursue goals of
philanthropists rather than goals of
nations as things might have done in in
the early parts of your career
yes well I'm all in favor of private
money but that's not new of course I
mean astronomy has always been supported
with private money they check telescopes
in Hawaii which are doing wonderful work
in astronomy these are ground-based
telescopes they were all paid for by mr.
Keck we have a long tradition in
astronomy of being supported with
private money and it's certainly private
money is much more pleasant to work with
you don't have to write proposals all
the time you don't have to write
progress reports every three months it's
a much more efficient use of money if
you can get it privately on the other
hand it's also true that the government
is doing extremely well people the
public is not aware of how wonderfully
well the government has been doing in
recent years I mean the Kepler mission
is a great example that mission which
discovered 4,000 planets around other
stars that was all done with government
money very efficiently I mean so the
government actually is good at that too
it's it's we need both one shouldn't put
them down just because they happen to be
government's and what the government is
not doing good at is taking risks and so
if you have something which is risky
then must better do it privately and
that's why the private companies are
doing so well at the moment because if
you want to have a really much cheaper
space propulsion system time especially
Space Launch System which is really
cheap you've got to make it risky and
and because most of the expense of the
government programs come from this being
so risk-averse everything has to be
checked over 25 times and the paperwork
is horrendous and that's the consequence
of not taking risks so that's why the
private companies can do much better it
seems like space launch which they're
starting to get doing now being risk
averse is just a way of making
everything expensive so switching in
like a switch from a controversial
subject like politics to a less
controversial one religion you don't
mind
so you're known for practicing Christian
as a practicing Christian or a
non-denominational Christian I guess
specifically so I guess well maybe
instead of me telling you what you are
because you could you maybe describe the
role that religion plays in your life or
has traditionally played in your life if
you don't mind and then I have some
follow-up questions on the relationship
between religion and science and more
interest to me of marchers to me the
relationship of scientists to religion I
think I think it's actually a
fascinating subject so how do you
describe your as it was it from your
upbringing or how was your upbringing
sort of theologically speaking and then
how did you evolve over time yeah well I
said answer the second question first it
I'm a non believing but practising
Christian and which i think is actually
a very large fraction of the practicing
Christians I've in my church in
Princeton which is Presbyterian they
they don't care whether you believe
everything that's not really to the
point it's a community and it's the the
the community of people who have a
loyalty to the church which is based on
other things rather than beliefs that
the community it has a very important
youth component it takes care of
teenagers there's a lot of activities
teenagers in the church they have
wonderful music they have several choirs
and they have of course the liturgy they
the order of service and above all they
have the literature the Bible and all
the the Bible is still the greatest work
of English literature and both
historically and at the present day and
that's what the religion actually gives
us whether or not you believe in the
details of whether Jesus really existed
or whether he was divine or human and
I'm simply not interested in that I
think clearly Jesus didn't exist and
he's a wonderful source of wisdom and so
I have enormous respect for him but I
don't worship Him and I think the same
is true of Jews of course even more that
many of my Jewish friends are practicing
but not believing that's this it's not
at all unusual and that's probably true
of Muslims too and you know it's it's
that's I think that's a happy state of
affairs you don't have to worry about
whether everything you've told is true
and you certainly don't have to blame
people who seem differently from
yourself I should also mention I mean
that I was brought up in the Church of
England which is in England of course
religion is sort of a question of class
that if you're upper class you're Church
of England if you're lower class you're
Presbyterian or Baptist
so it's very much of a social
distinction and so I had had a sister
who became Catholic because she couldn't
stand the snobbery and disk appeal in
churches so she became a Catholic and so
when I was in England visiting my sister
I became Catholic too I was went to Mass
with my sister so very comfortable there
and now I have a brother who is a
Presbyterian minister so I feel very
comfortable with her and to hear her
preach in her church and so it doesn't
matter to me whether it's Catholic or
Protestant or opinion whatever you want
Jewish I wonder you know many of our
colleagues don't share the ecumenical
thoughts that you've expressed I always
find it ironic because most universities
at least in America were set up first as
theological seminaries essentially
Columbia Princeton has a very storied
history with the Princeton Theological
Seminary greatest universities were sort
of established in this way and now it's
it's basically impossible to you know to
find religious studies on campus or at
least in many campuses and I'm familiar
with and I wonder if that's a product of
the more secular age that we've that we
may live in but in particular you know
I've heard it said about the National
Academy of Sciences in the United States
that over 93 or so percent of scientists
do not have a belief in God either our
atheist or do not or or agnostic with
only 7% that is to say having a belief
in theism as a traditional definition of
the word I bet the same is true of their
Fellows of the Royal Society as well
that there's a large number of
non-believers and maybe even active
non-believers that is to say not even
not believing but but trying to convince
others not to believe sort of
they're sometimes described by your
fellow countrymen Richard Dawkins as
militant atheists and I wonder what what
are your thoughts about about that and
why there is so much tension I mean it's
it's it's almost as bad as that the
tension is between philosophers and
physicists it's actually much worse than
that but why do you think there is such
a such a an innate resistance to to
religion on the part of scientists as a
general rule yes I think it's
tremendously exaggerated by the media I
mean Richard Dawkins who happens to be
the most notorious of these people who's
he's a militant atheist into it I think
he does a lot of harm he's telling young
people you have to make a choice either
religion or science but not both and I
think that does a lot of harm he
actually he turns off a lot of young
people who happened to be religious
believers thinking they can't be
scientists which is absolutely not true
of course in the past
I mean Newton of course was a very pious
Christian and a very serious Christian
and most of the great scientists of the
past were believers and until recently
that change came in in the 19th century
in the case of Princeton a person
university was a religious foundation
what happened in the 19th century was it
became secular rice and then theological
seminary was founded to take care of the
religious part of Princeton University
it was really a split in the university
will see a logical seminary became
independent and also theology Princeton
is secular and when they live
side-by-side and that's so that's been
the solution in many places so you
separate out there
religious part and the reason why that
happens is very complicated it's it just
it's partly just due to the American
Constitution which makes a separation
between politics and religion which is
certainly good on the whole healthy firm
yes but so that encouraged the
universities because I'm secular but of
course the same thing happened in France
and in other parts of the world in the
similar fashion around the same time so
when you when you look around the
scientific landscape at least in my
field of cosmology there's a notion that
has become almost synonymous with the
big bang theory which is which is the
epic of what's called an inflation this
early super rapid expansion of space and
time that is theorized to take place in
the very first few nano nano nano nano
seconds after the Big Bang and I wonder
your thoughts on not on inflation but
one of the consequences of inflation at
least as as proposed by many of the
theorists including Alan Guth and and
Andrei Linde and others who first worked
out the details of the inflationary
theory down to the level of perturbation
theory and structure formation and that
is the so-called multiverse which seems
to suggest that that our universe may
not be alone so not only might there be
a Fermi paradox within our galaxy or
even between galaxies but there might be
additional room and real estate for
Fermi's question to to be asked which is
that there might be an infinite number
or functionally infinite number 10 to
the 500th universes have been suggested
as not implausible according to the laws
of string theory and
relativistic early universe cosmology I
wonder first of all your your thoughts
in the multiverse if you if you have any
and then follow-up question about the
similarities between the sort of the
ability to test or falsify scientific
theories such as the multiverse and
where they fit into sort of the orthodox
conjectures of modern science so first
on the multiverse and then if we have
time to talk about whether or not it is
how it fits into traditional definitions
of science yes well I'm very skeptical
about theories in general and so I mean
inflation was a beautiful idea and it's
not really a theory it's a sort of a
model it's it's a magical scheme which
is extremely simple and there's really
very little evidence from observations
that it's true if it's a model that's
consistent with the observations it is
probably much simpler than anything that
nature would have devised Nature has a
habit of being complicated and so when
we look at themes for the first time we
usually have a simple model in mind and
so we look at the star and we think it's
very simple but just a big ball of gas
and you make models of it the problem is
that people who work with models tend to
believe the marvels it's it's almost
impossible to work seriously on the
problem without believing more than is
really justified and so it tends to
become thinner almost a religion that's
that you have a a mathematical scheme
which you thought it becomes in your own
mind somehow true and then you think
about it as if it were real nature but
when the time finally comes when you do
the observations
nature usually says it's wrong and
that's what I tend to believe much more
what nature is saying that I believe
what the astronomers are saying so
that's a best buy my own temperament but
the fact is that astronomy is amazingly
rich there's so many wonderful things we
are observing within inside the universe
and those that's what I miss excited
about then there are all these other
things which are beyond the universe
like what they call the multiverse for
which we have no observations nothing
but mathematical speculation I don't
find that so interesting and it's almost
certainly it has some elements of truth
but most unlikely it's anything like the
real truth and so anyhow as I'm
concerned I leave it alone
other people take it much more seriously
than I do
mm-hmm of course two of your countrymen
had sort of a difference of opinion so
one was Sir Arthur Eddington who said
never believed in observation until it's
been proven by a theory which of course
is the opposite of most ways that we
think of the scientific method and then
Karl Popper also said well he said in
contrast that essentially the
predictions of a theory which cannot be
refuted by observation or tested by
evidence that such theories and the
models that are spawned by the by these
theories would not qualify and his
definition is counting and as a
scientific pursuit it might be a fun
parlor trick it might be give give
employment to two astrologers and their
soothsayers as popper called them but I
wonder if this notion of falsifiability
does that hold any resonance tea in your
opinion oh yes so I mean
really agree with popper or Bubba that
the science ought to be verifiable and
but this of course an amazing fact which
that somehow goes in in the other
direction is in fact that mathematics
has been so amazingly successful in
describing nature so there is some kind
of I would say a really a major mystery
that so much of what we've invented as
mathematicians what looked like pure
mathematics finally after after a
hundred years or so we find it's all
there in nature and so there is a
possibility this goes against popper
that by pure mathematics you can
actually predict what nature is going to
do and that thus it does work so it's a
popper is not the whole story and it's
the real world is a mixture of popper
and Eddington that's that's what makes
it so beautiful that these mysteries we
know to understand I would like to say
science is really not about things we
understand science is about things we
don't understand
that's what makes it exciting and in
that sense of course science and
religion are not so different but both
science and religion are mysteries will
we have this amazing ability which we
can't explain to find out how they how
nature seems I mean I've always like to
say I mean we just are monkeys who came
down from the trees rather recently and
it's amazing that a monkey can write a
symphony or
or invent string theory or anything else
I mean the imagination which we have
wasn't required to survive in the jungle
or when we climbed when we were living
up in the trees and somehow this
imagination is a gift from nature which
we don't understand like many other
things
one more question before we turn to the
final question it's like it's the
penultimate question if you if you knew
that there was a god what question would
you most like the answer to if you could
sort of circumvent all the scientific
method and hard work if you could just
ask a question of this omniscient
omnipotent being what would that
question be
oh well closest it's it's hard choice or
some so many mysteries and which I would
choose but perhaps how did life begin I
think would be number one in my mind
that he probably knows one would hope so
job description
okay so I want to spend the last few
minutes talking about prizes and you
know that I'm quite interested in and
prizes and you've won so many of them it
would take the remaining all the
remaining time we have just just to list
them including one recent one that I
would do want to bring up but in
particular that what I consider to be
the world's most prestigious accolade of
any kind the Nobel Prize you once said I
think it's almost true without exception
that if you want to win a Nobel Prize
you should have a long attention span
get a hold of some deep and important
problem and stay with it for ten years
that wasn't my style you've talked about
that but I guess it's clear to me or it
seems clear to me that you never really
saw winning the Nobel Prize as a
priority many people as you know have
considered that you should have had a
share of the Nobel Prize that went to
the folks along with whom
you created a quantum electrodynamics of
the theory of quantum electrodynamics I
wonder how this you know you're losing
of the Nobel Prize and in my in my
language that have any effect on you or
where do you see the role of such of
such prizes
some say it's a curse to win a Nobel
Prize TS Eliot who won the Nobel Prize
for Literature said the Nobel Prize is a
ticket to one's own funeral no one has
ever done anything after they wanted
you've had such a remarkable career even
since since those heady days of
inventing quantum electrodynamics oh I
wonder what are your feelings on prizes
such as the Nobel Prize well I was
recently there's a wonderful was a
Jocelyn Bell she married Pernell so
she's called Justin and she's the one
who discovered pulse Asli that's right
pulsing radio sources in the sky which
turned out to be rotating neutron stars
and they have an enormous importance and
the dynamics of the universe and in all
sorts of ways it was one of the biggest
discoveries ever made in astronomy and
she did not get the Nobel Prize instead
her supervisor and the Hewish got the
prize and she was barely mentioned she
she was there a graduate student when
she did the work anyway so that's sort
of a famous example of wrong person
getting the prize and she was visiting
first and recently she's a wonderful
lady she's she was only about 20 when
she did the work and and now she's in
her 70s I guess but still going strong
anyway she's visiting Princeton of
course the students asked her the
inevitable questions what do you feel
about doctor well Nobel Prizes and she
said oh it's wonderful you know it's so
much nicer to have people ask you why
you didn't get the Nobel Prize the to
have them ask you why you did I feel the
same way it is anyhow
in fact of course we didn't worry about
it it was it really wasn't in our minds
when we were doing the work it I think
it's become much more worried about
these days somehow just because of the
media media pays so much more attention
to it than they used to and I don't in
those times when I was a graduate
student I don't think it actually was
talked about so much certainly we
weren't thinking about it much and then
it's certainly true I did not deserve it
because I was mostly just cleaning up
sort of cleaning up the mathematical
mess it was all just mathematical
details what I was doing all the ideas
were came from the other three so I'm
not unhappy with that at all one thing I
would like to to draw attention to is
last week it was announced that you won
the Highland Prize and so I want to read
the citation I believe this is from the
National Space Society organization and
the headline is Freeman Dyson famed
physicist wins the National Space
society's prestigious Robert a Heinlein
memorial award
so the Space Society members have voted
to give Freeman Dyson the prestigious
Robert a Heinlein memorial award this
award honors the work that he has done
as a groundbreaking physicist and
mathematician and as a major thought
leader in the science and space
communities over half a century and
there'll be a presentation in Los
Angeles May 24th through May 27th and
you'll be celebrated there I wonder if
you could give us a preview in any way
of the remarks that you might be
thinking about for your acceptance
speech of this wonderful award
yeah well applause no I have enormous
respect for Heinlein I mean I do read
quite a lot of science fiction and
Heinlein was very good as a spinner of
stories and I think science fiction has
been important
still is important for getting kids
interested in science and for giving the
public interested in supporting science
Heinlein was the old-fashioned kind who
just had people strutting around it's in
space anyhow what I'm going to talk
about it says cerumen is outrageous
comedy about what might happen in the
future that's what I think
science fiction King can't contribute to
somehow a lighter touch so you don't
don't all have to be so serious and so I
I'm promoting something called the
Noah's Ark egg which is a vehicle for
getting embryos into space very cheaply
so I think it might in fact have a
important part of our future I mean the
important thing is not humans going into
space the important serious life as a
whole it if you want to if you want to
flourish in the universe one species
won't cut it it's you have to have a
million species living together
that's where nature really can take off
and evolve evolution is not something
that's done by one species evolution
requires a whole ecology and it's a very
complicated and very powerful creative
thing and I think the Noah's Ark egg
might be the way to do it anyhow that's
what I'll be talking about very good
well I know that you said in the
beginning that you like to get the bad
news first but now the bad news comes at
the end that this interview has to come
to an end despite my desire to very much
continue to pick your brain but you'll
be around San Diego I know a lot more in
the future as the scholar and residents
here at the University of California San
Diego and I appreciate your visit and
congratulations on winning the Highland
as well thank you very much thank you
this has been into.the impossible a
podcast of the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination at UC san diego
we'd like to thank our guest dr. Freeman
Dyson and acknowledge our generous
patrons and sponsors including viasat
Inc members of the founders orbit and
the James biax Family Foundation your
support is much appreciated to find out
more about the Clark center and other
exciting projects research and programs
as well as how to support our mission
please visit imagination UCSD edu audio
production is by me Patrick Coleman
produced by Patrick Coleman and Bryan
Keating the only thing we can be sure of
about the future is it'll be absolutely
[Music]